The ozone photon was coming and then they start to win every
competition and I say OK, we have to do something.
So this is how the GTO 3 was born.
How's your relationship with Ozone guys?
I think it's still there is a chance to develop more
performance, but in the same time the key of success today
Paragolader is. Please tell us about Boob 13
without letting away any secrets.
What is up everyone? Welcome back to another episode
of Panic Nightingales podcast. I'm your host Aninda Singh and
as usual, we are coming to you. Definite life, but exclusive
from the Macedonian town of Crocevo, the racing capital of
the world. And today I have another very
special guest joining us this time around.
A lot of you know him, a lot of you have followed his passion
for quite a long time. And most importantly, a lot of
you have experienced the art of flight and all the joy that
comes with it because of this person I'm talking about none
other than the man himself, the force behind Jen Paragliders.
Mr. Jen. Hello, nice to see you.
This is such a big honour. Thank you so much for coming.
Oh, my pleasure. Mr. Jim, you happen to be one of
the very few founders of a brand who is still flying a
paraglider. And not just flying it, he was
also racing his own creations at the very top level.
I have a question, Sir. How do you?
Feel. Oh yeah, I've been flying since
1977, so I'm quite old. But it's flying is my like my
life. So it doesn't really see the
differences from the beginning to today.
For me, the flying is just a joy of life and things like this.
So I still fly almost everyday. Usually I'm testing the wings
with my test pilot and I designed the wings and I fly I
feel it change. So actually the flying is my
daily job. So when I test the wings, we
have test also full speed performance.
So we are I'm the full speed is I don't need a training period.
I'm almost every single days we do the comparison full speed,
whatever. So that's why I still can't
compete in the competition with the World Cup young boys.
So I'm I don't need to win, but it's a pleasure to fly with
this. And then also in the same time I
also compare my new wings in to see in the real competition.
This is how I fly. Still competition now.
Mr. Jim, there's a saying called that there are no old and bold
pilots. But are you challenging that
saying since long time because I see you pushing full bar with
the lead gaggle or the first transition.
So is this the old and bold pilot that we're looking at?
Just yeah, it's like habit. When you fly long time in the
competition, it's usually you push the bar and then it's just
to eat. So I don't see why I don't have
to do. No, I love it.
I love it. I used to have the passion and
all the courage. Do you have any idea about the
amount of hours that you might have accumulated?
Just a rough number, Like are you at 10,000 plus or less?
You know what? What do you mean total?
Indeed. Yeah, ever since you first
picked up the glider. I don't know.
I don't. I never count my hours flyings
but it's I've been flying since Hang Gliding so I do a lot of
Hang Gliding competition too. So after I changed paragliding
and paragliding, competition and paragliding is like my daily
job. Testing whenever the weather is
good then we are on the hills to fly, testing top landing,
changing. So usually per day in a good day
we are, I am like 4-5 hours in the air.
So it's a lot so. Yeah.
The reason why I ask this is because there's a theory which
says if you do something for 10,000 hours, you become natural
at it. So it seems that you and your
team are close to anybody who flies for 656 decades.
I think that is the amount of time.
If you say 70s, you have been flying and now we are in 20,
half of the second decade of this millennia, then probably
it's almost like 555 or 60 years that you have been in the game.
Yeah, almost 50 years since 77, so we are in 25.
So it's almost 48 years, 47 years, Yeah, I think I'm the
only one in my place in Korea, all my flying, Hang Gliding
friends, they stopped flying since long time ago.
But I think I'm the only one who still fly today.
It's such a big inspiration that there is somebody having the
passion, the courage, the time, money and the energy and most
importantly stayed safe all throughout.
I think that itself is a podium or a medal and it's like staying
safe to practice it. So could you tell us a little
bit about origins of flying in South Korea?
How was it? What was the history of free
flying in your country when you got into it?
When I begin Hang Gliding this it was very beginning of hang
glider. So this hang glider was never
able to do any cross country flying.
You take off landing with the Rogallo.
I don't know if you know that just very basic hang glider and
beginning of hang glider. So you just take off and go land
in one minute. But that was big pleasure.
And then when paragliding start, there's not many place to fly in
Korea because the old mountains was no road and things like
this. But we found a new place and
we'd speak with the local government and put the new road
and kind of thing. So we, I did a lot of open the
flying site to the City Hall or local government.
And then also in the very beginning of parallel, I think I
was young and I had strong passions.
I had a big school, yeah. So I think that was, I don't
know how this energy came from, but I do 24 hours work almost
and then teaching the peoples and like they have no idea.
So I have a lot of experience from Hang Gliding.
So I know what you have to do in the air.
So when paragliding was begun, I knew the air.
I knew how to thermaling but by then actually the paraglider was
almost similar to parachute. So it was never possible to any
cross country flying. So then slowly the paraglider
developed and then start to make a distance flying kind of thing.
So why I was fully concentrated paragliding in Korea, was in
Korea and there's not many place to land.
There's lots of power lines. The Korea has small tiny
countries. Actually I like paraglider where
you can land anywhere. You don't need a lot of big
space to land like Hang Gliding. So that's why I was really
pushing the paragliding sports in Korea.
So now the level of Korean pilots are really good.
Some of them is like world class pilot.
So it's I'm happy to see today the young guys doing good in the
World Cups and international competition.
So I'm quite happy and I did a quite a big job in Korea.
That's so nice to hear that you basically mentored.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Which is reaping the benefits
from this generation? Tell us a little bit about the
origins of your brand. When did the idea from a pilot
to a brand owner come into your life?
Actually I was working for some other brand called Adele and
then Adele was big company, but they didn't have designer.
So they just anyhow they made something.
And so then I join and I make this Adele number one in the
world. So this air there was very big
and huge communities and World Cups.
So many people fly their gliders and then somehow in the 1997,
somehow it was time to leave. So I didn't want to start my
company. I want to actually, I wanted to
take a break, but somehow somebody's asking me to to
having competition wings. I had the time.
So I draw gliders and then I asked some small factory to
stitch and then send it to Japan.
And this Japanese guy went to the World Cup with this wing and
they start to go on the podium. It was in for European in the
World Cup. It was big shock because no,
none of Asian was on the podium ever.
But with the strange wing they start to go on the podium and it
was a big shock in the World Cups.
What hell is this? Who's this new cover with all
the new technologies? So then I told them don't say
this is designed by Zine, just to name it Boomerangs.
So this boomerang was going three of them Japanese guys
start to go World Cup and then they start to win all in top
three. Wow.
So then big pilot like Hans Bollinger, Jimmy Parker, by the
time there was the top pilot, the world champion and all these
kind of guys are calling, they finally they knew that it was
from Gin and then they called me say I come to Korea tomorrow,
OK, And then we discuss and OK, OK.
Then I had to build small company called Gin Gliders and
then I didn't have other models, only boomerangs.
So you started with triple CS? So it was a funny then Boomerang
was winnings. Yes, this is how the Jingle Aid
was born. That's so interesting.
OK. How did like what was ozone not
existing at that time or what was your biggest competition to
the boomerang at that time? The ozone was starting the
nearly same time as Jingle Aiders because the Robbie Witter
who was one of the my test pilot before and Robbie Vittal is the
world champion of Hang Gliding and world champion of parallel
gliding and he was working for me as test pilot.
But then he start Ozone and I start ching gliders and Ozone
was not my competitors. By then.
The competitors was like Advance and Nova.
Who else? Yeah, they were string was not
too much. So the advance was good.
They have a good team. So they had a nice wing for the
competitions and we have a good model too.
So yeah, it's nearly same time Ozone start and until 2009 Ozone
was OK, there's Brent, but that none of them was winning any
competition. But 2009 in the Super final
World Cup in Italy, Porgio Bostone, we had full team,
boomerang team and then the Ozone came with A2 liner.
Ah right, Charles Kazu and Russell Wooden coming and then
they win 4th, 2nd and from 3rd to 11 was boomerangs.
That was big news. Then 2010 you see everywhere
ozone one day to next days you see it's was a big evolution.
So since then ozone take the top and they are still there.
So basically 2 liner tech is what propelled the ozone?
Yes. Mr. Jin, I have a question.
When it comes to designing, what is the difference which makes 1
brand better than the others? Because let's say when you came
out with Boomerang in the beginning, the other brands also
were designing really good gliders which were being trusted
all across the world. And today when Ozone is
designing 2 liners which are winning, the other brands are
also designing 2 liners that are winning.
But at that time, boom Boomerang technology was dominating and
now Enzo technology is dominating.
So what is it that makes a glider better than the other
brand? I think the success of Boomerang
was not only performance but also safe, easy to fly.
That was the key. So there was some glider maybe
have a more performance, but in what I say is over the
performance means when the glide is easy to handle then you
perform better. Success of Angels 3 is also in
the beginning was not, but today they really make the wing more
easy, safe, stable, in full bar, that kind of thing.
So people have confidence. The pilots are not stupid.
They know if I take this wing, I say easy.
So today the whole community, not like it was 20 years ago.
Today's Facebook Instagram is for everywhere.
Information spreads. Very fast, yeah.
I think the the key of success is not only performance, but
also how easy to handle in full speed.
And in the during the race if you get collapse, what happened,
that's very important. So I think that many other
brands is not even attempt to design the these two liner
composition rings. Actually the market looks big,
cool light composition model, but we don't really make money
out of the composition rings. The you sell.
ABC gliders are really the main business.
Probably they make good money from industry because the whole
world, so many industry, yeah. I think when it comes to R&D,
researching and developing gym has been at the forefront of R&D
for quite a long time. So what was your idea when you
set up the gym company? How did you want to do the
research and the development in your company?
Did you hire some people or did you just focus everything within
you or did you look for support? What was the idea?
Behind in the beginning honestly there was none of the designer
had the experience like Eugene, all the brand when I look the
designers they are they are starting the paragliding and I
was flying from Hang Gliding actually.
So I have more understanding about flying and skills and so
when I design and testing wings and I know what the air is doing
in turbulence and whatever. So that was the big difference
from the beginning when I designed some wing and finished
product, then my wing was selling better than the others
because it flies better, they glide better, whatever.
So that was the my success in the beginning and then the we
were really had a huge team because when you have so many
competition pilot, you are getting so much feedbacks.
Then after you can understand what to design.
So this was the big community and this big community was
helping me to design the wings better.
Same like now Angel have so many pilot fly angels and they have
entire informations coming to them and they know what to
change. So this was the same thing
happened in in June before so then today the my experience was
good. But then since 10 years ago,
what's important is, is not only experiencing it, the real
research was actually needed. So start to work with the the
R&D, with the university research.
So we start since last 10 years ago, we start to develop the
paragliders. But any university, they are
good at airplanes, but they didn't understand paragliders.
None of them was able to help. But I found the one good one and
then this guy was a student, but then he become a professor and
then he start to help me to develop the parallel wings.
So today we have a big support by the government.
So last time when we designed Wave leading Edge, we get $1
million support by the government to work with this
university. So we spend the $1 million to
finish the formula of this wave leading edge that.
Is unbelievable. You're still telling me that
there was administration ready to spend $1,000,000 on our
sport? This is current government was
helping the small company like Jin Gliders and then
collaboration with the university.
So this lab was really interesting to work together
because they they start to understand the slow.
Wings like paragliders. So this is how the wave lineage
was born. And today we have a even bigger
amount of the budget, $2,000,000 for four years.
So we are now starting about the wing shapes, wing tips,
whatever. This is exciting.
It will come soon, but you need the money.
What I wanted to say is you really need to calculate and
testing things like this. I don't really use the CFTCFT.
Result is computing is you can use it as CFT is a computing
program. OK, fluid dynamics.
Yes, yes. So this yeah software then you
can take it as a reference, but we do more in the wind tunnel
test. The wind tunnel test is actually
you get the real more practical data.
Yeah. So I'm quite happy that we are
working with this lab. That's nice I think.
Are you the only brand who has wind tunnel accessibility?
Because I have never seen any other brand of.
I heard some company has a small wind tunnels in the company, but
we are working with this university who has the wind
tunnels, so it's interesting to see this.
The internal test result is very practical.
This is it inspires me how you challenge the status quo time to
time, be it with the original Boomerang back in the day or be
it with GTO 3. Now GTO 3 is a thing that I'm
very curious about because it seems to be the racehorse of gin
brand right now coming up. All the SRS comps the pilots are
trusting is the community is happy with it.
The full bar performance is pretty amazing, but I believe
you developed Boomerang earlier than GTO three.
Could you please tell us a little bit about the technology
that this two liner EMC has and how is it like becoming the
status quo of the SRS and two liner series?
We knew we we learn a lot from the two liner competition wins
and bring it down to the C Class because in the beginning the two
liner was the image of two liner was dangerous, more difficult
and things like that. But then when this knowledge 2
liner, I mean for us all also, we made a lot of mistakes for
sure, try and errors, and then we learn more and more.
So then today we can like move around 12, for example, super
easy, nice handling, safe after huge collapse, the glider never
rotate. There's no big energy to turn or
whatever. So it's safe winds.
So we learn and because of we we did a lot of we experience and
we have this wave leading edge and whatever.
So then after we really want to when the sea class accepted by
EN with the folding lines, then we start to develop the two Lion
Sea gliders because we know 2 Lion is easy to fly and also the
you can really enjoy the speed cross country flying.
Yeah, the but it took sometimes to make.
When I designed the Bonanza 32 Lion Sea it, there was no SRS in
a competition. So I make a Bonanza 3 purely for
cross country safe. When you do the cross country,
let's say in the Alps for example, then you're going to
fly sometimes the Lee side. And because you fly 7-8 hours,
nine hours and for sure you, you will go to the Lee side few
times, then there's a lot of turbulence.
So that's I, my focus was to make the wing very stable
instead of very high speed or high performance.
It's a good enough for cross country flying.
Then after Bonanza 3, the SRS start.
So then again the Ozone photon was coming and then they start
to win every competition. And I say, OK, we have to do
something. So this is how the GTO 3 was
born. How's your relationship with
those guys? Nothing wrong.
I have a good relation with the Luka monks and it's.
So nice to hear like there's a healthy competition and I think
healthy competition is is essential in any community to go
in the right direction because of course dominance of 1 brand
is very good for them. The monopolization is never good
for the industry as a whole. So I think with GTS 3 coming in
and challenging photon dominance, it's just so nice to
see as a pilot, as a consumer that there are more choices to
pick up from. Let's talk a little bit about
wave leading edge. You released a video about the
R&D that has gone in. It said it is influenced a
little bit from the Vale Fin design animal Vale Fin.
Tell me the what were the origins of this idea?
How did this? Come this technology was been
has been in the industry since long time actually.
And these back whales has a big how we call fins and then they
have these tubercles and these tubercles the lot of scientists
study about why they have such a huge whales as these tubercles.
Then they found the tubercle is working and reduced drags.
And so they are using these tubercles in the some kind of
fence or in the even in the airplanes?
In the airplanes, yes, in the small airplanes.
Oh really? So I, when I get this proposal
by the professor, then I said, OK, let's try.
So this university professor, he was very keen to develop this
cubicle on paragliders. So this is how I begin with this
$1 million fund. We asked the government, we
apply in this project, then government to check, and then
they said, OK, it's interesting. So they pay $1,000,000.
So we have the money to develop this wave leading edge.
We named it Wave Leading Edge, but it's actually called
Tubacles. Tubacles.
Yeah. Wow.
So this is how we in the beginning we made a few
mistakes. We put everywhere the tubercles
from the entire wingspans, then the glider performance good.
But then it was the wing was spinning very early and the
stalls on the wing tips very quick.
And so Professor he, I asked him this is not good.
Then he discovered that normally the waves has a straight wing
and then it has tubercle, but our parabola has a curvature,
the wind floor is different. So then we discovered that the
60% of the wing spun, we put the tubercles and then the wing tip
is normal leading edge. So then this was working
perfectly, no stolen wing tips because we need all the lifts
and performance in the middle and then tips are reducing
drags. Usually when submarine style
harnesses, cocoon style harnesses came, the logic that
was given was that the fluid, in this case air, flows better on
smooth surfaces. Because there's less drag, there
is easier flow of the wind. Tubercles make the surface a
little bit rough, glitched I would say.
Do we see tubercle design coming to the harnesses as well in time
to come, or is it just the wings that can benefit from the snow?
I don't think cubicle on the harnesses.
I don't think so. Because I'm talking about, let's
say the golf ball analogy, like golf ball isn't completely
smooth. It has small dimples which help
it cut through the air in a much more efficient manner.
So it is similar to the typical design, not exactly the same,
but it attacks the same level of physics.
So do we see something changing in these super smooth cuckoo
style harnesses that we have in time to come as well?
If you find the like this temple fabrics for sure it will work
and we were already discussing about these matters, but today
what's urgently need is today with already the submarine
harness types is already there. Actually if you can reduce this
arm where you full speed you have to hold the B and you
always walk so your hands I say this is a huge drag actually.
So if you can reduce the these arms drag while you are in the
full speed, this will be happening soon.
Are we seeing that brake handles being controlled from Urda
Cocoon at some point? No, I think, I don't think so.
It's very dangerous. It reacts to very slow and yeah,
I'll build some brand want to to the arms going down and no, but.
Like a closed canopy is what my question was that are we looking
at paralleling going into closed canopies eventually in time to
come? What do you mean close?
Something which has a covering over the pilot's head as well,
right? We are just like until the
chest. OK.
You mean the cockpit completely like the sailplane?
One day, some other, maybe some brand will develop it.
I quickly want to talk about the topic, Mr. Jim, about
performance versus price optimization, $1,000,000 is a
huge blessing in any companies R&D.
Paragliding itself is an expensive sport.
The customers obviously complain about money all the time that
the gear is getting expensive. The manufacturers say that the
raw materials are getting expensive and the yarn makers
and the ones who supply raw materials are saying they are
doing the best they can. So when it comes to making
performance, is cost a big factor which holds back
performance? If somebody comes out and say is
that all right, I will set aside 10 million or 15,000,000, then
can we see super performing paragliders?
I think it's still the IT. There is a chance to develop
more performance, but in the same time the key of success
today Paragolader is safety and we increase the performance a
lot. But in the same time the wing is
safer and easier to fly compared to 20 years ago, 30 years ago.
Today the technologies developed this very super good way.
All the pilots are they don't feel it but before when it's
very strong condition you wouldn't fly because to
turbulence. But today like yesterday saw
strong window, nothing happened because it was easy and stable.
So that's the benefit of paragliders and so I think they
we always concerned about the performance, but in the same
time how easy you can handle and how stable and you feel
comfortable in the air, that's the very important for the
market. OK, tell me a little bit about
safety. What defines parivir safety?
Because we keep on moving slowly towards less collapsible wings
like the ones which are harder to collapse, and we have
technologies like rust coming in.
What was the thing that reflex coming in?
There are some technologies like this which help the pilot in
reducing the collapses, but at a lot of times, collapse is also a
safety mechanism because otherwise there's a chance of
falling into the canopy completely.
So where is the sweet spot and how do you as a designer look
for that speed sweet spot when it comes to letting the wings
collapse? Because the turbulence otherwise
will be very dangerous. We learn the last 20-30 years
about these factors and we are flying with the and parallel the
need to be collapsed. If the parallel is not
collapsing, then it will be more dangerous actually.
But what's important is after collapse, when the wing is
slowly opening or not hugely impulsive openings and like
pastime, then it's more dangerous.
So we learn how to design wings more smooth after collapse.
And this is internal structure and then also the innet shapes
and all these are developed last 20 years.
So actually the internal structure was developed in a
good way, safe and everything was more easy.
Yeah, more the glad is to more damped, yeah.
OK, a question comes to my mind. Let's say your wing is collapsed
50% or 60%. Your one side of the riser is
gone, so now the whole of the tension is on the other side.
Is it theoretically possible that if the turbulence of the
air mass is very disturbed, it can collapse the flying side as
well and your glider can crumple into a small ball?
Possible, yes, if there is so much turbulence then this could
happen. But today the if you have a such
a huge collapse and the wing will not completely destroy even
if in the strong turbulence, if you hold the brakes correctly
and if the wings are opening radically impulsive opening that
is more dangerous because then it is the very impulsive opening
will react the other side collapse, then it's you might go
crash. Yeah, I saw that in China last
month and during the World Cups the take off was very Cliff and
very dangerous. So one one of the Chinese girl
flew this photon and then after shoes collapse one side and then
opening was incredible impulse violent and then whole glider
just collapsed like this and then crashed the Cliff.
So she hurt bit, but I don't know what's happening.
But the it's it's air. It happens with the modern
technology wings. But compared to, you know,
before it was, it is now more. Safer than me?
Yeah, yeah, I. Agree.
I agree. Don't you think we can have some
sort of a slider technology like the skydiving canopies have to
reduce the impact of these violent?
Why? Why is that not being
implemented by paragliding? Sliders technology will it's
completely different. You can use it on the parachute,
but not paragliding. Yeah, the I just want to add on
the way of leaving it, the wave leading edge is the airflow.
You read the about the wave leading edge.
So the airflow usually when the air comes in the leading edge
and then right off the leading edge, the separations and then
create the turbulence with wave linear edge, the separation
start quite late. So the air is smooth in the
leading edge part. So the wing has no shooting
tendency at all after some situation.
So we discover that this wave leading edge is helping really a
lot after the huge collapse then the glider reaction is really
very slow because this separation stay very bad.
If it's here near the leading edge, then the glider will
shoot. Yeah.
So that's huge difference with the wave lineage.
So we are keep developing the whole range of the wings with
the wave lineage. That's what I was going to ask
actually. Thank you for bringing us back
to the topic that VC2 liner technology going only from open
class to Triple C down to EMD and now even C Class gliders are
pretty much only being sold in two liners where the money is
lying for the manufacturers. Michael Nestler, probably
somebody that you know already. He has been a designer for the
German brand of Swift. Swing.
Swing, I beg your pardon? And for anybody who's interested
in listening, just scroll up in the index.
We have had a very informative podcast with Michael Nestler as
well. He's the first one to bring 2
liner into B&B class and even get a certified with approval
from DHV, the German watchdog in this.
So are we looking at 2 liner technologies and new
technologies like Wave Leading Edge finally making their way to
beginner class gliders as well? Because they do promise safety,
but at the same time they also promise more performance, which
eventually translates into more fun for everybody going out and
choosing airtime. The currently the EN rule is if
you use the folding lines with the two liner, you cannot make a
collapse with the fold without folding lines.
So the Nestler was clever to put one line on the front which is
just hanging and then that's why they call they passed EMB.
But actually it's not 2 liner, but wave lining edge is
different wave lining edge. I can use it in all we in the
beginning we testing the wind tunnel with a high aspect ratio
and now we have now tested in the wind tunnels so with a low
aspect ratio. So we have new typical shapes
for the low expect ratio. So we are actually working on
the high B 2.5 lines. We say wave leaving H wing which
is Explorer 3 is coming. So the this one we know the
benefit of wave leading edge. So what's wrong with the low
aspect ratio Mr. Jim, there was a very interesting development
before the wave leading edge that I saw on your website and
that was a new fabric. Now fabric industry is mostly
dominated by Dominico and Porcher.
That is the trusted suppliers. A lot of brands use them.
A lot of Flyers pilots are also comfortable with them, but Gin
was the first one again to challenge the status quo and
bring out a fabric called Munjin fabric.
Yes. Can you please tell us what was
this all about and how did that happen?
Actually, the Munjin is a very old company who used to produce
for the military parachute fabrics.
The older fabrics today or for paraglider today is nylon 66.
Everybody knows that the low material come from DuPont.
It's everybody used that one. And so the parachute industry
has been, I don't know how many years they are using this Rift
top technology. Just today, paragliding fabric
is Paragliding fabric is how to coat these raw materials.
That's the technology. So it's just the coating which
is actually being researched upon.
Not not only the coating, also the how to wave weave the ribs
and things like this, So they design to make it light and
strong enough and also air policy.
So they in the beginning Meangjin didn't want to take any
risk. So they are OK to make a bottom
surface fabric and then profile fabric in the beginning.
But they are afraid to use the fabric on top surface because of
the airport and so on. So we think encourage them to
develop it. And then so they were that we,
we spend some money, Ding glider, pay them to develop the
fabrics. So finally they made the fabric
and then we made the test wings, for example, the one school
glider and one tandem gliders. And we send it to one in France
and one in very like a desert rough condition.
The ground is not grass and things like this.
Then we get the wing back and check the porosity strengths
again. Then we test again as it took
some years to to reach the fabrics on top and then we were
sure that this is because we've done enough test.
So the Meongjin start to come in the market and then we make a
special contact when we spend the money because we pay the
development. So, so when the fabric comes and
we only we use two years exclusively then they can sell
after two years. So we are still doing the light
fabric, we are working like 21G or whatever.
So we have a special contract and because we test everything
for them. So they went Meongjin and
Jinglei is quite close. So then after Meongjin, when
Jinglei was using Meongjin, then everybody contacted Meongjin.
So many other brands now using the Meongjin too.
How is it different or better than the other offerings?
We have a very strong relations and then also the guy his father
was very good engineers and then his son is now take over the
jobs and then he's very clever and then he is quite listen to
us. So when I asked him to develop
this and they're really coming to too.
So other brand like Dominico is hardly order them to what to do.
They have their rules and they just test it.
That's Dominico is impossible to communicate for me.
So Meongjin is same country. So yeah, yeah, it's that's why
we can develop the one which we want.
So this is very good for us. Do things like I see you're
doing a lot of in house things, let's say with the gin lab
opening up. Are you willing to open up this
at a certain stage later on, of course, at the like royalties
being paid out so that eventually in future other
brands can try and benefit from these technologies?
Yeah, I'm OK to do that because it's there is a certainly the
benefit wavering it is helping for the safety and whatever.
So we actually we have a patent Tony, if anyone can use the way
of leading it and but we wait until some years for sure.
You wait until at least half of the podium is, or the complete
podium is filled with boomerangs.
Once again, good old times. I hope so, yeah.
Why not? Why not?
Mr. Jung, I see that you have been one of the industry leader
in a lot of you know, tech Democrats are coming out with
all their force. What do you think about this new
technology, this new way of having fun?
Actually the Tim Bollinger is working on it.
He like to play these things. So we are using the kite, one of
the kite from Hans Bollinger and then his father Tim Bollinger.
So Tim is using the kite and we modify the this kite and he's
now testing this one. Yes, but I don't know it is
already the Skywalk has a huge market for that.
So we are not very interesting to come in because we first we
want to take over the SRS and then World Cup, my first
priority. And then we also in the same
time we should make a very good school gliders and intermediate,
which is the most selling part. And then also the tandem is a
huge market for Jingle lighters. So we are the leader in the
tandem business in the market. I think you must have definitely
seen the B bit. What was it?
Golden. What is the name of the?
Brand gradient gradient. Yeah, what was it about that
wing that made it so famous in tandem?
I don't know it was light and an easy take off Egypt flare that's
all for the tandem is what all you need is that.
But today the fuse 4 our Fuse 1234 is the huge portion in the
market. So I think we are the leader in
the tandem business now and then now gradients are I don't he
shut down and the Super aborted and after that there are quiet
yeah. I think hard riding industry is
a pretty brutal market. Yeah, yeah.
And that is what inspires me about you, that you have not
only stayed relevant, but you have stayed competitive and are
still challenging. Yeah, yeah.
Which brings me to one of the final topics of our talk,
because we'll be running out of time very soon.
Boom 13. First of all, the colour looks
fantastic. Yeah.
Thank you. I was gliding with you the other
day and I was like, oh, that ring.
I could definitely look at that for a while, but then you zoomed
past pretty effortlessly. We are on.
We're in two very different classes.
Anyways, please tell us about Boom 13 without letting out any
secrets. Oh yeah, it's been.
I start to develop this boom, boom around after boom around 12
with the wave leading edge was very success.
We won one World Cup for second, third with the wave leading
edge. Room 12.
Clean Sweep. Yes, that was very big success.
And then Ozone come with the submarines, so they win again.
OK, so then I start to make the wings.
It took some time to come with the room 13.
Yeah, today what you need is the competition.
It's almost full speed. You never go through speed.
You almost never go. Honestly I think I'll be
surprised. Even in thermals people are how
late they are letting off the bar.
Yeah, it's a really incredible competition.
So this is the key of the winning wins, how fast you can
go and then how much better glide in full speed.
That's the big things. So we did actually the lot of
internal test and then we work a lot for the wing tips.
Yeah, I think now quite good. We will see after this
competition. Do you have an approximate date
in your mind when you think you will be able to finish the
product and bring it? On Oh no, it's done.
Finished. Yeah, it's certification is done
and we are certified six days before the World Championship
starts. So we are definitely we will
send this wing for the World championship.
So here is the only one. Glad I fly when I have a better
result, but I'm old men and my goal is to show my wings during
the thermal wings and kind of things.
Yesterday I was climbing better than few guys in the gaggle, so
I was happy. I think you'd flying a triple C
on full bar at this stage itself is quite a humble rag to say the
least. You know, like old men like me.
Don't call yourself old, Sir. I think you're young.
At heart of that is what really matters.
I forgot to talk about Carrera because Carrera has AB class
certification, but a very nice handling.
Could you tell us a little bit about that because obviously
there are a lot of market players, pilots who are
interested in rings of that certification?
Carrera was designed for C Class initially, but then during the
EN test the test house say you have no C it's completely CB so.
That was a welcome surprise. Yes, it was surprised and I
said, OK, then we take it as B because in the marketing I
discussed with my marketing teams and B market is for sure
they're much bigger than C market and no one has a
expectation 6 on the B glider. And so I said, OK, let's see how
it goes. So we launch and yeah, because
the Carrera was just boom like crazy.
It was big success. And today the biggest market is
the B class market. Yes.
So we are now making two different to be lobby and high
B. It's coming before Copica.
Wow. So I'm pretty busy to finish
this one. I can imagine, and I'm very
thankful that you gave me an hour long conversation out of
your busy schedule because I've been chasing you for more than a
year now. And finally, it was such a
welcome surprise when I bumped into you at this world.
I was like, yes. Thank you very much.
Now Mr. Lynn, before I let you go, we have a tradition on our
show where I ask my guests to share one flight that has
remained with them throughout their flying career so far.
And with almost 5 decades of sharing airtime, I know it's
going to be hard, but if you can share one flight, the memory of
one flight with our audiences, I'll be very thankful.
Memorial memory of one flight, how it went, or what was if you
remember anything. My the best memory was in during
the World Championship in Switzerland, Verbier I was
flying alone somehow 1993 and Switzerland there was a during
the world Championship somehow I was leading and alone.
So I was low in the valley. It was almost like a very stiff
mountains. So I was like a soaring up and
then I met the dead. I would call deer deer with the
big OK. So the animal deer.
Antlers. Big one.
So I thought maybe this is a male and then must be some
females and then looked down. There's a female was climbing
such a stiff. So when I make one soaring, I
went to the other side when I come back and this animal was
there. And then it was just the
feeling, it touches my heart. The animal was the look, my eyes
and eye contact. And this feeling was amazing.
This is you can't explain the feeling with the nature, how the
how beautiful paragliding is. This is amazing.
And the one more I can say is it was in Russia, Kurai Valley.
There's a competition and we flew there with a choose eagles
like big vulture. There's almost 2 1/2 meters
wingspan. I was fly with this vulture and
somehow my direction was to go to the West, but this vulture
was flying a little bit different direction.
I follow this vulture and then actually I did the faster call,
then I was straight and then with the Vulture we circling
together and then I was afraid that this if the vultures attack
like Australia, they hit the wings and kind of things.
But this vulture was very gentle and flying.
Find the thermal. For me, this kind of nature
feeling, this is a beautiful beauty of the paragliding.
I can totally relate to this because it happened to me once
in my early days in flying. In beer billing.
We have Griffin vultures, massive, as you said, 2-3
meters. I was still learning to thermal
and I had this vulture circle super tight.
And I would never bury my brakes so hard and take a circle so
tight because I thought I was told to wing.
But I was like, no, if he's circling that he's in the core,
then I can trust him. And I did that.
And within two or three circles we gained a lot and I just
started screaming. And then the virtual looks me in
the eye and that eye contact. Yeah, this is all.
Eye contact with wildlife out in the nature is magical.
Like magic that's completely agree.
This is magic and touches your heart 100.
Percent. That visual has stuck with me
until now as well. Mr. Jim.
I usually say this with a lot of guests that have quite a few
experience that there's no one single episode that will do
justice to the amount of knowledge that you can share.
But for now, we have come to an end of this episode so heartfelt
thanks for being on the show. It means the world to me and I'm
sure the audiences can relate to the same as well.
That we wish you all the very luck and simply cannot wait for
you to bring out your awesomeness to the audiences.
Thank you very much. So thank you.
Hey everyone, for those of you who have listened this far, I
just wanted to drop in a note of thanks because you guys are the
ones who are actually making the difference.
It means the world to me whenever I see audience
retention rates remain high all the way to the end.
And I'd like to add on by saying that if you have liked the
content that you just consumed, do consider liking, subscribing
and dropping in a rating wherever possible.
Because that is one way we can let the algorithms of all of
these streaming platforms know that this episode is worthy of
being pushed out to more pilots in the community.
So collectively, you and I can make the sport a safer and a
more fun place to be. Well, on that note, thank you
once again for joining me today. And I'm really looking forward
to connecting with you in the next episode as well.
Until then, I'm going to say what I always say, and that is
stay tuned. Stay excited because this magic
is just getting started.